um well thank you everyone for welcoming
me
i feel a bit jet-lagged so uh i said no
powerpoint today i wanted to have a
conversation and
you know we've spent some time talking
about about this class and about what
you're learning and about the center and
so i'm really excited to be here
i'm really excited to talk about how i
started my company it's been 18 years
now so
uh feels like a very long time and i
think it's also because it's been a
really long time so
i want to talk about how i started i
started my company back in 1996 and so
it feels uh very ancient the world was
really different the tools i had
available to me to do that and to start
are very different than what i think
young entrepreneurs have today and so i
want to talk a bit about how i started
and and focused on the work we do at the
agency and then what we do now and
i hope to
save kind of some significant time to
have q a and to engage with you and
answer your questions
so let me start off with
how i started buzz so i
never ever thought i'd be an
entrepreneur in 1996 that was not a word
that was really kind of known to me
i always thought i'd be a beauty editor
and so i was very focused on fashion and
beauty and i wanted to be you know an
editor at primarily a teen girl magazine
kind of like 17.
and so at 16 i applied for a job with a
newspaper for girls out of new york city
called the new girl times and at the
times i
primarily wrote
product reviews focused on you know my
first column ever was for a company
called high intensity that made very
cool jewelry
and i found during that process of
reviews that when i would submit the the
column back to whoever gave me product
they would always say if i keep sending
you product will you tell me what you
think and at 16 i thought that was the
coolest thing ever that there were tons
of companies who would send me products
if i just told them what i thought and
so
i thought that was the gig i didn't
think it was a way to make money it was
something i became really passionate
about and you know even at 34 i still am
so passionate about trends about new
things about you know whether it's
reading about a new destination and
cunning ass traveler it's something that
still fuels me today the idea that you
know there's so many new products to try
so little time and so
uh back in 96 i remember
a lot of pr
uh type people were my quote unquote
clients and i i started getting phone
calls like i have a friend she works on
this brand you'd be really cool to talk
to and i didn't really understand you
know what the conversation would be i
was literally a suburban teenage girl um
i should i guess go back and say i'm the
oldest of six children and so
uh you know the eight of us what i was
kind of the odd kid doing this
interesting thing and since all of my
siblings
have really interesting careers and do
really interesting things but at the
time it was something very different
very new and so my parents were like why
is ups you know why are ups and fedex
here every day so no one really got what
was going on i didn't really get what
was going on but it was happening really
quickly and so by the time i was 17 i
had about 40 clients and again i used
that word very loosely because i hadn't
yet
had that moment where i realized i could
make money doing what i was doing
and so i started to recruit my friends
and say if i give you guys some of these
products can we all review them and i'll
tally our scores and i'll send this
little report back to
our client and so
that worked for a while and then my
friends would say well i have a cousin
in texas and she would love to be
you know one of your trend spotters and
again
think about the time we're talking about
i said well how would i communicate with
her you know i had just gotten an aol
email address at 16. so
the idea of technology and connectivity
wasn't something that was yet really
relevant i think at that time and the
way to communicate the way our network
communicates today didn't really make
sense at that time
and so it continued um
pretty small until i got to college and
as a freshman in college i had two
really important things that happened at
the same time first i
took my intro to business course at hood
college i went to a women's school hood
college in frederick maryland and i took
an intro to business with the head of
the department and at the same time i
was working on one of these reports for
a fashion company and my client at the
time called and she said i'm going to
tell you something really important i
just received a report i reviewed it
with my team
and yours is ten times better than a
report we paid twenty five thousand
dollars for you have a business it's
called market research and that's all
i'm going to tell you go figure it out
and so
during office hours i went into dr
jose's office i said here's what i've
been doing for the last two and a half
years what do you think and
she took some time and kind of just
stared at me for a while and then she
said i want you to take an independent
study with me next semester and let's
see if we can't make this a real
business and so
i was really fortunate at that time to
uh i like i always tell dr jose i got
beat up for 13 weeks in a row uh into
creating a business and marketing plan
but i still use those plans today and it
was really fortunate because when i was
in college at that time so i think 97 to
probably spring of 98
it was um right around that like dot-com
boom and so
when dr jose and i talked she said i
don't want you to get caught up in what
at that point seemed to be kind of a
trench so i want you to build a business
that's a solid business and if there's a
digital component that's great but
you've got to build a solid business and
there i mean to help you understand what
was happening at this time in the
internet there are websites like
kpasa.com that were raising 50 million
dollars and then went bust you know a
couple months later so it was very
different than i think kind of the
builder movement that's happening now
and a little bit i'll get into some of
the trends we're studying um
and so i understood okay i need to build
the solid business and i was really
fortunate that when i needed to
understand statistics i could go and
talk to a professor and if i needed to
understand how psychology and sociology
played into my business there were
people that were available
for me to talk to so of course i'm a big
advocate of building businesses while
you're in school i think that i always
say my education definitely worked for
me um
and it was really important for me to
actively be a student and also build
this business and so
you know i can work with dr joe's and
realize okay i have services now i can
make money
and started working really hard at
recruiting call you know clients and by
the end of my college career i was
working with verizon wireless i remember
spring of my senior year doing a
research project for them and you know
flying california and back to school for
class and i spent my junior year instead
of studying abroad i studied away
lived and worked in chicago which i
really found to be kind of the mecca for
marketing and so you know 22 i'd had a
lot of experience at this point six
years of running this business and
i still thought maybe this was just a
really interesting hobby you know i
didn't actually think this was going to
be my career for as long as it's been my
career and so
i still remember the conversation with
my advisor when i said oh you know i
just i just watched legally blonde i was
just talking about this last week in
another conference and thought i should
go to a law school i don't know people
who like fashion and beauty go to law
school i don't know i remember him just
saying yes you could go to law school
because you're a very good student
and not knowing that this is what i
wanted to do and i've been getting some
media and i thought that
the media was focused on my story of
being this interesting girl doing this
interesting thing and even at that age
you know 21 i didn't think that was the
way to build a business you know so
focused on one person one story and i
also didn't think it was the right story
i didn't think it was the right message
because at some point you have to grow
up and you have to be respected as a
research company or whatever it is that
we that we were becoming not there's
this cool girl that does this cool stuff
with product you know i felt like there
was a timeline on that
and so i said to my advisor you know we
we really talk spent quite a bit of time
different sessions talking about should
i go to law school should i do you know
vastly different things should i go into
the field you know and just apply for a
job and you know i remember my
girlfriend's senior year reading like
this book on quarter life crisis and it
was really funny they were like oh you
of course don't need to read this book
i'm like i probably have the biggest
crisis here of everybody
but i decided i said to my advisor at
the time
i said here's what i'm going to do
i think that now when i graduated it was
spring 2002
and illegal downloading had become a
major issue or it was becoming kind of a
thing you know it was a sean fanning
movement and there was a thing
and um
during the spring of my senior year i
spoke at a music industry conference it
was a very interesting conference
because there were three other
presenters from really really big
research institutions and they were
saying things to
the audience who you can imagine or
people who are quite concerned about
illegal downloading and they were saying
things like it's not going to be an
issue only 17
of people illegally download music and
then i get up you know this senior in
college who has a research panel and at
that time should back up and say
our network grew to 9 000 people solely
because cosmo girl magazine wrote two
sentences about what i was doing and i
got 15 000 applications from people all
over the world who wanted to be buzz
spotters and so
you know we really created this great
network and we had done research and
found of the 500 people we surveyed that
99 of them had illegally downloaded
music within the last 30 days and so
obviously we were presenting two very
very different uh
sets of data and so
uh i kind of was disheartened i was cut
out of an article in billboard and i
thought okay well that is what it is and
and so back to that conversation
dr weinberg i said you know what i want
to do i want to i've always wanted to be
a liaison between consumers and people
who target them and at the time it was
teens and then as i you know grew older
as young adults and now i'm 34 so we say
consumers
and people who market to them i said i
want to talk about things that other
people don't want to talk about and i
don't have any skin in the game to
necessarily need to go one direction or
prove one thing i'm really curious to
why consumers do what they do and what
their interests are and so presenting
that research was to say
you might be right maybe only 17 of
people illegally download music i just
have a belief that the 99 that are in
this demographic i'm dealing with
have a really huge impact and obviously
we we know now that that did have an
incredible impact on that business i
think still today
it is impacting the music business and
and how that business is shaped now and
so you know that's always my example of
the power of millennials and the power
of consumers when they decide that
something is or is not working for them
and so
you know i decided i was going to try
that out for a year i opened an office
in new york city uh and i worked there i
lived in south jersey and i still live
in south jersey today and so did that
for three or four years and
i guess the
most interesting thing that happened
during that time
was i was featured in a cover story for
oh magazine and so at 25
you know having that kind of oprah stamp
of approval of my career was huge i
didn't think it would be not that i
didn't think the oprah brand was huge i
just didn't think anybody cared about a
kid who was doing research in new jersey
you know i just didn't think that was a
story that would resonate with people
and obviously
if you're lucky enough to be touched by
the oprah brand it does turn to gold if
you're doing something good and so it
was great for us and i i still remember
clients coming into the office like with
my actual page from the magazine kind of
like we saw this and so
uh that was great for our agency and i
think we kind of you know again other
profiles in 30 under 30 and
all kinds of awards which
for me and i think you understand if
you're an entrepreneur you have to be
fascinated by your work and passionate
about it and the other stuff is just
stuff that happens it's not something
you pause and i think you know my mom i
realized
recently has a clipbook of all of my
different media but for me it was just
this is another day
and it's another day that i get to do
something that i love and so
um we continued to grow the network
continue with our research and then
you know the economy took a turn which
was interesting because what happened is
our business uh really diversified so
we got into influencer marketing again
by accident i had a client call and say
you know the girls i talked to about
beauty were having some issues launching
a product at sephora do you think we
could engage them in influencer and this
was probably about 2007 so i don't think
you know it was right around the time a
buzz agent was coming along and i
thought i don't know that we're that um
you know i've always really wanted
that lane of consumers being able to
openly and honestly express their
opinions to brands that was a really and
still is a very core
value of our company and very important
to me so that means if i have to say
something that's not great that that has
to be okay and that also is a big reason
why
i don't have a team of 50 60 70 people
because sometimes i do have to make
decisions that i think are a little more
ethically driven for our business and so
um
at that time i wasn't sure it would work
and we tried influencer and it did it
worked really really well and so we
incorporated that into our services and
so
you know when the economy took a turn it
was a lot of traditional things that
were getting cut and people reinvesting
into the type of work we we do and so
you know we have over the last 18 years
worked with 135 companies um
and i guess some highlights for me would
be at companies like american eagle
outfitters sony music
dell microsoft and so we've gotten to
touch some really big brands and i've
learned so much from our clients and
i would say personally for me
one of the more fun accomplishments a
lot of people talk about my business
book but not so much about my children's
series so i
write a series for 7 to 12 year old
girls it's published by harper collins
children's books it's called mackenzie
blue
and it's really focused on a girl that i
think is kind of like a modern ramona
and i've written five books in the
series we've sold for 200 000 copies so
it's a really fun you know i feel like
it's my fun passion project um i'm
working on another series right now uh
it's all about a girl who can't tell a
lie and what happens in middle school
and so
uh you know writing and creating
mckenzie and creating a character that
is really beloved by girls has been an
interesting experience for me especially
as a researcher because through
mackenzie through
you know her life i get to see girls
react to her and really get to
understand kind of what's going on in
the life of a 12 year old girl and and
that was something really interesting
and i guess as a final comment before i
open up to your questions um
two years ago i was elected to the
united nations foundation's global
entrepreneurs council and so we are
charged with um bringing innovative
ideas to the un and if i weren't working
for myself i would
absolutely love to work for the un and
so
it's been a really incredible experience
that's why i'm actually in san francisco
now i have a board meeting it's our last
and so
um it's just been an unbelievable
experience for me for the last two years
and earlier this year i got to spend
some time in uganda i got to visit a
refugee settlement and
meet entrepreneurs
and when i think about what
entrepreneurship means to me now at 34
a bit more established and kind of what
your opportunity is you know when i
started out there were not a lot of
tools
and there weren't a lot of people that
could help other people rationalize what
i was doing you know you guys live in a
world where everybody knows who mark
zuckerberg is everybody knows what it
means to be an entrepreneur
and everybody understands the upside you
know when i was doing it i was that girl
doing that weird thing and people were
saying to my parents your daughter's so
smart
why isn't she a lawyer or a doctor you
know they just didn't get it and so
you know i am now members of you know
many different associations that didn't
exist when i started and so i think that
the entrepreneurs you know
entrepreneurial spirit and especially
what i got to see in uganda
has really made me an even bigger
champion of entrepreneurship you know
seeing innovation that can drive and
create business opportunities in uganda
and meeting you know female
entrepreneurs who are
you know creating
an amazing life for their children that
are able to send their children to
private schools
just because they're entrepreneurs and
they have simple businesses selling soap
you know
having farms is something that was
really interesting to see and so i guess
at this point i would love to open up
for questions and you can talk about my
work we can talk about trends that i'm
seeing whatever is interesting to you
um i know first i can touch um like
almost like an ethical quality in your
business from time to time i was
wondering if you could just elaborate on
that sure um can you repeat the question
sure he's talking about really the
ethics involved in what i do every day
and i think that
marketing
um
marketing is an interesting area when
you talk about that right it's the
images that we create the messages that
we send i think that there was a time
um where i talked to my clients about
kind of a one-way funnel where we push
things out to consumers and
and imagine you know when i was a
teenager i'll use myself as an example i
feel like gaap dictated my whole life
right it's like when their fall campaign
came out that's who i was that's what i
was going to be
um and if i wanted
a really a specific shoe there was no
online shopping i went to a mall that
dictated what i had access to
and that's that was that you know if i
was a suburban jersey girl this is what
i could have access to and i'm sure we
remember those times where our friends
would travel to the west coast and we'd
get something there that we couldn't get
at home and so
i think it created this funnel where
marketers could
project onto consumers what was cool and
there have been documentaries i think
there was a particular one i saw called
the merchants of cool where sprite
actually said we project onto you the
image of who we want you to be
um
and that for me was definitely a bit of
an ethical dilemma and i think i
was coming about in a time where you
know technology has created um this
interesting democracy where consumers
can i i feel have the power and can
dictate things to brands you know gap
changed its logo consumers didn't like
it they changed it back to the old one
you know that would never happen in my
opinion 20 years ago
i think your ability to shop online and
to
make those types of decisions totally
changes the playing field you know it's
not a dictatorship anymore if i don't
like this i won't do it you know if i
don't want to buy a car i can use uber
now you know if i want to be a conscious
consumer there are ways i can do that
and so
i think that
for me i've always erred on the side of
just working with brands that i really
like
and brands whose products i am
passionate about
you know and it's hard because there's
some you know for me
can i say i was so passionate about dell
um
you know
i
may not have the products i got to work
on were amazing products and for people
who who need pcs but what i was really
passionate about was michael dell's
entrepreneurial spirit and that he is
really a true entrepreneur who is
fascinated by new things and creating
new things and so that for me
was someone i could get behind and i
think that
in general i would tell you 90 of the
people i've worked with have really
wanted to connect with this consumer and
the people who wanted to dictate to them
weren't people that would work with my
system anyway because you know the
consumer and that research and data you
know we have a process we call connect
brand impact understand and the first
step in that process is bringing in the
voice of the consumer so you can imagine
if you're a marketer that you already
have your plans and you just want me to
verify what you're saying we probably
wouldn't be the best match so i i think
that earlier in my career it was
something that probably came up a lot
more where now i feel like it's the
reverse for brands are understanding
that you dictate what's going to happen
and they're just trying to figure out
where they fit
what methods do you use where do you
look to spot trends and what trends are
going on today
um where do i look where do i spot
trends i
i was at starbucks today and i was
sitting next to a very interesting
millennial having a conversation about
her job at salesforce and her co-workers
and i wish i could have taped that
conversation
i was fascinated by how quick it was
happening and what she was talking about
and so i travel quite a bit i travel
outside the u.s quite a bit but
i don't believe that great trends are
started in new york in la you know i
i think that especially today you know
trends come from all over the place and
i i am really fascinated by people you
know and i think that
to think that you can go to one place
and one source and get everything you
need is very antiquated you know there
was a time when people would produce a
trend report and send it out and say to
everybody these are the colors of the
season you know and i think again going
back to the technology piece consumers
are it's so fascinating to me you know
think about
when when fashion blogging became a
thing right so think about a magazine
like lucky that when you open lucky
today i feel like fashion bloggers drive
that book you know where
years ago it was editors dictating to us
what was cool and what was edgy and now
we look at really cool people and those
are who you know i think olivia palermo
probably tells more people what's cool
than you know a fashion editor and so
it's interesting to see that power play
where now it's like we all have to work
together
and so for me
um
commuting is a great time you know if
i'm in an airport i can always tell when
a trend is mass
based on my time in the airport i'll
give you an example two uggs and toms
when you get on a plane and everybody
walking past you no matter what age is
engaged with a certain type of brand
that's when you can start to see
mass influence and there are times where
i remember seeing two people at an
airport with toms and then i remember
every other person having a pair of toms
and so
i'm always looking at that moment that
breaker moment when something is really
becoming mass you know we had a trend a
couple years ago we called mass
exclusivity which is the idea that
everybody um wants mass products that
are customized from for them kind of
driven by ipod
so
you know i i
don't think that
trends come from just one place or just
one person because at the end of the day
you know my clients want volume and so
you know we're right now creating
something called the millennial brand
index where we're ranking brands in many
different categories um
and i'm talking to someone who is going
to be part of a judging panel for this
project and she said to me you know
you're talking about all these companies
that are really interesting of course
the ones i like like warby parker i love
warby parker she said what i want to
know is
if the girl in kansas loves warby parker
and i think that is a great question
because we sometimes can become a little
obsessed with what's happening on the
coast and we don't realize it's a huge
company a company huge country uh with
so many different opinions and so i
tried to not
let one idea dictate when i think
something is cool um
and i also don't think that i have the
answers i think you find a lot of people
i don't know if you guys experience this
i see a lot in business where it's like
because i have a child who's 12 i
understand all 12 year olds you know
or i know millennials my child is a
millennial and what i always take the
the approach is that i don't know
anything and that i think
every day something is changing and
every day i'm getting new new access to
new research and information and so i
always try to approach it from i'm just
here to learn and to observe and to
interpret and i don't really have
an end goal from it i just want to know
what's interesting and so
you know i think you have to to kind of
do the work i do just be very open to
learning something new and not i think
the most important thing is to not go
into it any assignment for me with any
preconceived notion and and sometimes i
think that's hard with my clients
because they sometimes arrive at the end
and then want me to justify it and so
that sometimes creates a dilemma i think
oh okay
i like that airport story i'm
just wondering props on a more personal
thing in the past few flats have gone on
what stuff have you noticed what's
caught your eye um what have i noticed i
think oh and i have to answer your
question sorry about trends i'll tell
you a bit about the trends we're
predicting for next year
um
i think what i'm noticing lately is
what's missing
i'll give you an example i don't think
we figured out
a charging solution that makes sense for
as many devices as we all have
i see a lot of people crowding around
very few outlets
so
needs of technology um
i see
in general airports becoming
a more interesting hub of shopping you
know
specifically i can speak to philadelphia
yeah it's not a joke that like the best
shopping is in the airport
and so the airport has a destination but
just from people in general it's that
they want to be connected and that we've
got to figure out how to make that
connectivity easier you know when you go
to many other places outside of the us
it's really easy to get online and to
have great wi-fi and to be online
and so figuring out you know
that issue and
it is it's funny i'm seeing more
problems lately um i see a problem of
food quality in airports and what
consumers are looking for and what they
have access to
so i think i see kind of more
opportunity and then in in general with
consumers um
it's very interesting you know uh
there was a time where uh teenagers were
called screen agers because they were
looking at so many screens
and what fascinates me is looking at
boomers you know i think everyone's so
millennial focused that they don't
realize that there are other generations
that there are really interesting things
are happening and so i think watching um
kind of the non-millennial engage in
technology with technology with so many
different forms of technology and
figuring that out is something that's
interesting is to really see you know
how integral it is and that i think
we're still a little bit behind it might
probably not be the case here but there
are places where
you know what consumers need in that
space and how connected they want to be
and that that connectivity is not
available at that moment
and in general to your question about
other trends so we've got um
working on our top 10 trends of 2015
right now
and we're focused on some things like
the makers movement um
and and talking to some of our
buzzbotters what's interesting is there
are those that consider themselves real
makers who really make stuff and they're
really put off by the idea that
everybody thinks they're a maker but i
just think it's something that's
becoming a bigger consumer play and
we're seeing it in different areas i was
on my flight over reading an article
marie claire when they were talking
about how to make the perfect palette
and you can buy this palette called a z
palette that it's a plain palette you
can literally if you want to put your
makeup in the oven and you can unglue it
and create your own palette and so
i thought about you know how interesting
it is that we deconstruct makeup that we
pay a lot of money for to create our own
custom solution and so
you know we've talked a lot about
customization before
and the need for customization but
to actually give consumers the ability
to make things and participate in this
different way
is something new
we're talking about this idea of being
selfie conscious
and it's not at all
that millennials are self-conscious is
that i feel
like and through our research we've seen
that there's such an emphasis
these days on perfection
you know that there was a time where
it's like you could just walk out
looking however you looked i mean i i
went to college at a time where girls
were going in like pajamas and uggs or
whatever boots they they're wearing at
the time of sneakers you know and so
to think of a time now where everyone
has to think of your instagram feed and
how good everybody looks all day long
it's that pressure of you have to look
good all day long because there's a
filter for that and why didn't you get
into this top college and why aren't you
going to this top here and so it's the
pressure to be in all the right places
doing all the right things and looking
good and not looking stressed that i
think we're looking at and
that data is really important to our
clients because as they start to create
brand messages it's important to
understand just what's going on in life
for the average millennial
um
and i think we were exploring another
trend called insta feed but i think the
team is like moving that into selfie
conscious where i was looking at the
continuous feed that we live in where
every moment in our life is something
we're documenting and not just living
and how does that affect things in
general
we're talking about fitspiration
fitness and wellness and and it's
interesting um again i hadn't read marie
claire in months and so i'm catching up
and listening to reading this editor's
letter and she's talking about how
they're totally changing the health
section of the magazine and it's no
longer about like how to do the perfect
crunch it's now about like
a much more lifestyle approach to
fitness and again instagram's become a
big inspiration for this kind of thing
but thinking about the images of people
who are so healthy i mean how many
people pop up in your feed that are like
i'm working out and you know people like
jen seltzer whatever her name is that's
but who are in vanity fair for you know
how amazing their butt looks and so
again it's the the power of image and
how that's coming across and that medium
to say okay now i have to be fit and
think about like soul cycle whether you
go or not you know what this thing is
right it's like a coal right i love when
workouts are called cults but it means
that they're building some kind of brand
culture that people associate with in
some way and so we're looking at that um
also exploring net neutrality
uh it's something that's come up
over you know that's one of those
moments where i said um
i never tried to say what i think a
millennial will or won't do i remember
when we did our original research on net
neutrality and i said i don't even know
if this is
an issue they even know about you know
and i was so wrong um just in and not
only the knowledge but also um
why it was important and i think that
there
there's an interesting trend happening
now where traditionally
parents told children what to do right
and they were the authority and we've
explored this in different trends like
hand-me-ups where millennials were
actually handing up older phones to
parents because of shared cell phone
plans and and the millennials were
getting the better technology
and there's also this divide where
they're also explaining technology and
and that's something that's become
a really interesting thing to explore
right when you think of very
traditional companies think of like food
companies grocery stores how they talk
to consumers about what's important and
their issue their image of family and
what they project you know a trend of
who it becomes a lot of like who is the
making the main decisions in the
household and so
you know exploring that kind of trend um
i'm trying to think there's anything
else that's really interesting i mean
that's a preview
so far i think um
i like selfie conscious i like looking
at
what that means and looking at how also
to your question of ethics are we as
marketers putting that pressure there
to look perfect and saying that
perfection has never been more
affordable you can dye your hair in 10
minutes why would your roots be showing
it's so easy to fix you know as we
create really easy fixes to things i
think we also don't allow room for
imperfection and so
that is creating you know
it's it becomes a predictor of will you
as a generation push back on that you
know
i think we also look at
your
um position on government
you know and and this has been a really
interesting thing we we pull this a lot
um
and we found that in general
millennials might be a little more
centrist than people think you know when
we did research five or six years ago
the percentage of millennials that said
that they were democrat was
you know
much larger than what we're seeing today
but then also
we're looking at the implications of
even if they're number one one thing one
trend that's interesting they don't
identify um we we did two types of
identification are you democrat are you
republican are you independent or do you
think that you are more centrist like we
use different words and got different
responses and then becomes the idea
totally separate idea of that they don't
think government is actually working for
them
and in that case they feel like other
millennials or other people are better
solving problems outside of government
and mtv's done a lot of research and a
lot of work around this and
that really creates an interesting
conversation around problem solving and
if millennials start to approach problem
solving outside of a government
structure what does that look like
and so i think um
this is a year of for us
asking really interesting questions and
just looking at metrics and data i think
it's one of those kind of transitional
years to say okay like we we know the
traditional things are happening right
like digital is more important than ever
before that your digital natives and
that you know for brands i have to speak
in this way but it has to be authentic
like i think so many of those things now
are known
um
i think what's happened is that it's
become a year of
like i don't know if you all ever feel
this way but i feel like people talk
about millennials like a species they've
never seen before instead of just
understanding like you have to engage
like you would with any other
demographic and there are a lot of
people out there that talk about what
what what all day long and no one talks
about how and so i think for us as an
agency
next year is really about having a
conversation about how you know how do
you engage how do you know it's
important
and how do you take into consideration
all the trends we've talked about from
you know mass exclusivity to a couple
years ago we talked about warholism
which is the idea that all millennials
believe they can be famous it's not as
interesting as it used to be yeah i
remember growing up in a time where only
seven real people ever made it to tv and
they were on mtv's real world
you know now
think about your younger siblings you
can record your own show on your
iphone you know cut it put it on youtube
and you're instantly famous to your 100
followers overnight and so
can people sell you fame the way they
used to be able to sell to my you know i
i i guess i'm technically still
considered a millennial but i'm the
oldest of the millennials so you know i
might even be like the youngest gen xer
and so
you know the power of celebrity to
someone my age is very different you
know and i i even take it younger um
fisher price created a toy
it's a karaoke machine that you hook
into your tv and a little girl little
boy sings their favorite songs and sees
their face on tv
how do you then explain to them there
are people who are super famous you mean
on tv like i was just on tv two seconds
ago you know so that idea
of what fame truly means i think it's
something that's really
changing also
you know i was probably into my 20s
before there was perez hilton but you
know the minute you start drawing on
celebrities faces a kind of
it's an interesting value proposition
you know that's why we start to talk
about this bigger concept of are there
really true celebrities left are there
really true stars
because you know i think that there
there are entertainers there are people
that we allow to entertain us but are
there people that we kind of uphold as
this
unbreakable celebrity image that there
was when i was growing up i don't
necessarily know that that exists so i
think that there are a lot of questions
to answer right now
especially in a business where it's all
about understanding people uh
what would they say most interesting
sure i'll repeat the question so i i i
was just saying that i've seen so many
people and interacted with so many
people i guess who what segment or what
groups have the biggest impact on me and
how i see things
um
is that pretty much the essence yeah and
i guess just being people in general
what's been most valuable
okay
so i think there are probably two
experiences first i would say post
recession
talking with tweens i'm completely
fascinated by tweens because they have
more technology than we've ever had um
it is something that's like digitally
native for them so i explain it like you
know for people my age we didn't have to
discover tv right it's always there it
was always interesting it wasn't a big
new thing that happened in our lives we
get it tv is awesome um
same way a seven eight year old sees
technology it and and and when i was
writing my book i had this theory that
technology was ruining millennials and
what i actually realized is that it's
the other generations that have the
biggest issue because millennials have
always had it in a very appropriate
place in in
in their lives in your lives where it is
what it is i can you know and when you
want to spend time with friends i find
that the engagement can be much more um
i hate to use the word real but you know
you understand the place of technology
and so that was an interesting finding
and so when i think about tweens their
access to information and just how smart
they are
um
i'm fascinated by them and i we were
doing some research and my favorite
quote ever we asked tween girls how has
the recession impacted you and a girl
said i've not been impacted at all my
grandma just gave me twenty dollars and
i thought like i just love the optimism
in that like my life's great i have
twenty dollars life is awesome
and i love that
you know for them anything is possible
they're not quite yet at the age where
they have any reason to kind of be
defeated it's like anything's possible
i'm going to keep moving and i've got
the tools to do it and so when you see
girls who can you know mix their own
music or what technology is doing and
allowing children to do and how imagined
they can be that's fascinating to me um
and i'd say another group
when i was in uganda and met
entrepreneurs there i realized that we
truly do not understand what it means to
run businesses with challenges you know
i walk into a room
i know that if i flip the switch the
lights will work i know where the
nearest bathroom is i know how to get
out of the room in an emergency i know
that if i send an email my internet is
going to work and
to go to a place where none of those
things are certain and to see people
still work so hard and come up with
unbelievable solutions you know i was on
a remote island called busy island and
met an entrepreneur who had developed a
solar backpack that basically lit this
clinic where women would have to go if
they could get there to give birth and
when if they happened to give birth at
night
there was no light so babies were born
and the first thing this baby is doing
is inhaling smoke you know and so we
don't think about those things about the
impact of those things and to see an
entrepreneur you know they came up with
a solar backpack now there's lighting
simple solutions and so
i think so many of us spend so much time
thinking about very complex things and
to see
entrepreneurs focus on
things that might seem so simple but
we're so life changing for so many
people you know we also met a group of
stanford students
recent graduates who were living in
uganda and had come to open a company
focused on click clean cook stoves
and it was amazing because no one
understands
the importance of a clean cook stove
that if you cook over an open fire it is
the equivalent of smoking five packs of
cigarettes a day and think about the
fact that most of these women are doing
this with a child on their back and so
the child is also inhaling smoke they
came up with a solution that's less than
ten dollars that heats food in this kind
of clay pot for five hours and so
to see
how
you know the developed world was working
with the developing world i think was
really interesting and i've spent so
much time i think trying to think of
these really grand ideas and to see that
something so simple you know
meant so much to so many people i think
has been interesting and the last one
was uh actually this was a a day a
global accelerator was an
entrepreneurship day at the un
and entrepreneurs were pitching us ideas
and one guy had created a um a bicycle
ambulance which really made sense for
parts of africa where he was using it
and again we think of such big
technology and this was really the
safest
best solution at fifteen hundred dollars
and
and the statistics and research he had
done and how many lives he had saved it
was unbelievable and so
i think that i walked away from that
trip realizing that it's it's the small
innovations that sometimes can really
have the biggest impact and if you take
away the comfort that we're used to we
just had to you know other so many
entrepreneurs people who created clean
filtration systems that change the lives
of children at boarding schools so the
idea that i think for me at this stage
it's thinking how simple can we be to
come up with with solutions that's been
most interesting
so i've got a couple questions i want to
ask that these guys get
answers to
you're in the business of separating
uh finding signals amongst noise
and i think one of the biggest areas of
noise or questions is you know what
should i do with my life
and
lots of people have passions
few people are able to pursue their
passions and actually convert those into
real businesses that they can make a
livelihood after and thrive in
how do you know and you've done this
multiple times you know in multiple
different four ways when is there enough
of a signal to indicate that a personal
passion
has
you should have enough conviction behind
that personal passion to pursue that as
a business when your parents are saying
go to law school go to medical school or
every all of your friends are going and
working for the hot company
um
so i i'm a big fan of not drinking your
own kool-aid um
i think first i always start with what
what are you passionate about because
the thing that people don't tell you
about entrepreneurship is sometimes it
really really sucks and so
you have to really really love it
because the days that really suck really
really suck and so
if you're not passionate about it that's
the day where you're kind of like i'm
over it this is done and that's that you
know so
that piece is so important and i think
people i've seen recently it's like well
i can make money doing this thing but at
the end of the day i don't care how much
money is in a deal there is going to
come a time where something is just
going to be like not for you and you've
got to have that passion to say i'm
really i really believe in this thing or
i just love it you know every day i love
the job that i have and i love what i
get to do
and then
i always say knowledge is power so the
minute you have an idea you know we all
have the ability to be researchers and
you really need to independently not all
of your friends and family they love you
they'll tell you
i was fortunate that my friends and
family didn't really understand what i
was doing so they couldn't have told me
they thought it was great anyway because
they didn't get it but what i didn't
realize at the time was you know early
on those 40 companies that thought that
my insights were interesting kind of
prove that i had a client base before i
even knew what that meant and so you
really have to spend the time
saying what's my total market and what's
my target market and you always have to
be able to answer that question not i
really think this is great because it
doesn't matter it you know we're not
that great you know and there are people
you know i think what's interesting
today is i really do believe that there
are entrepreneurs who are creating
solutions that
will change the world and are changing
lives every day and making our lives
whether it's more beautiful or easier or
more creative
but at some point they had to qualify
that and so i would say you know and
quantify it you know what are your total
and target markets and my favorite thing
is when people say there's no
competition there is always competition
as a marketer i will tell you consumers
can choose to do nothing you always have
competition and so you know take a
minute and be independent and and say
you know how do you qualify the idea
who is your test market we all can find
100 people to say is this something
you're interested in and then
is there a way
uh to prove the concept can you start to
sell something at least you know to one
client and how do you get through that
sale process and and then always be kind
of refining don't be so set on this is
the way it has to go and always be in
that research phase um but i i always
hear especially with technology i think
it's a little bit of different story
right because there's the like analysis
paralysis when do you launch a product
when do you let people test it
what's great about technology is
consumers always from the minute it's
launched get to tell you what they like
and what they don't like and so you know
get yourself immersed in the ability to
hear what your customers want from day
one i think would be the most important
yeah that is always the most important
unders the empathy how and okay great we
go
hi i
talked earlier about some problems that
marketing has in terms for example of
putting pressure on
people always to look good always to
have you found yourself
in a position
that
you had a request from a customer that
conflicted with your ethical views and
in case you had it how did you cope with
that um so every client
and repeat the question just first sure
so the question is have i ever had a
client that kind of conflicted with our
ethical views of the company and so what
most people don't know is that we have a
panel of our own buzz butters that help
us determine if a client is someone we
should work with and that's always a
part of our process because you know i
now have thirty thousand buzz butters
all over the world seven thousand mom
spotters so i've got thirty seven
thousand people that give their time and
energy and when appropriate contract
with our clients and are paid to give
their insights and so it's a really
important network and you know i want
them to know we're always representing
their thoughts and views and so you know
it's happened a few times where things
just didn't make sense for us but
it comes down
for me is is someone trying to dictate
something or are they truly do they
truly believe in their product and do
they truly believe that they want the
customer to be as excited about this
product as they are you know so if i
have a client that's really not into
what they're doing that's not the client
for me because the amount of time
my team and and myself personally that i
will dedicate to a project to get
something to launch it's a lot of time
you know i always say i can always make
more money i can never make more time i
can't get that time back you know and so
that for me is the biggest thing do i
want to spend my time engaged in this
issue with this client and obviously 18
years into the business i think
have the ability to say yes and no
much easier than maybe i even did when i
was younger but i you know ignorance is
bliss at 22. i probably said no to
things that i should have never said no
to but i didn't care so
you know that's always been what has
driven me in this agency like i said
earlier we might be a lot bigger if i
were willing to do things and take on
some of the clients but if i don't
really believe in their product it's not
something i'm interested in and i just
want to clarify it doesn't mean that i
think every product has to be healthy or
good i think that there are some brands
today that are on this healthy good kick
that we all know we do not go into those
restaurants or into those places to get
something healthy or good we go in just
because we like it and it's interesting
you know so i don't necessarily think
that we have to we're also in a place
where we're like saying this is bad and
that is bad and i think it's consumers
we have to say i like this so i'm going
to do it or i'm interested in this so
i'm going to eat this it doesn't mean
i'm going to eat fast food every day but
if i want to go have a burger i'm going
to have a burger and that's fine and i
think
that's what i appreciate about
millennials is the idea of like it's
fine you know if i want to eat at
chipotle three days a week that's
actually cool and it's fine and so i
kind of like that approach to things
can i ask you a question about gender
and identity for the millennial
generation and is it is it an
interesting question is it an issue so
is being female an issue if you with
whatever you want to pursue is being
black an issue with whatever you want to
pursue and is it an issue is it a
liability is it an asset
what's your read and take both
objectively and personally yeah i you
know it's funny um
i was asked that question when i got
older and i didn't get it and i said you
know
at least speaking for my my personal
career i came up at a time you know in
96 before backstreet boys and britney
spears and el girl and teen vogue and
teen people and i kind of rode into the
teen wave and i happened to be a person
who just had more insights than anyone
else and so i'm a big believer that at
least for me the only color people saw
was green you know my ability to make
money i always say that i'm like the
only color people saw with me is green
um
i think that
there's this is one of our trends again
for next year we're talking about this
power girl trend and
i'm a little put off personally it's
probably the most controversial thing
i'm gonna say today
um by people
who think they need to tell girls that
they can run as fast as boys today right
you know i have a niece who's five i
never want her to hear that i want to
know i want her to know to run fast you
know she's growing up you know my
sister's sociology professor
you know she thinks her grandma's
awesome her aunt runs a company phoebe
already knows she can do whatever she
wants to do with her life and so i'm a
little put off
by that older brand and again even my
journey right that would be like me
saying guys entrepreneurship is so hard
you don't know what it's like for the
last 18 years like my world my journey
is very different you know i couldn't
build a website for less than a thousand
dollars get business cards for less than
35 dollars and have a business up and
running be a legal legal zoom in two
days that's an opportunity you have and
i think i have to
respect that and so i'm a little put off
by campaigns where it's like girls are
just as good as boys it's like i don't
need a campaign to say that
um
and it's hard because i think that
are there inequalities that exist yes
but also i can't truly speak to that
because i've always created my own job
my own opportunity and so
you know i will say one of the things
that made me really love dell
was they talked about empowering women
and every time i was in a meeting there
there were women running the show in a
way and really empowered within that
company and so it was great to feel like
i wasn't just saying something and then
sitting in a room of all men dictating
and so
that's important to see that if you're
promoting a company culture that you're
living it and i very much felt that they
were
um but yeah i have a problem with i
think girl girl power is the issue of
the day and so
people have decided that you know and
there are a lot of trends we can speak
to in politics that we can see we're
trending toward this movement and so
i i think that millennials see
through all of that yeah um i just think
that pandering it's like oh now we're
going to talk about girls and how
awesome girls are and i think that
um
you know toys for girls and things like
that you know i didn't have a course in
school that was like this is math for
girls you know most people don't know i
took advanced
math and science classes from middle
school until i graduated college so and
it didn't even go through your mind that
that was an issue until somebody said or
that girls were like my girlfriends were
like sitting next to me in class is what
we did and so i have a problem when we
kind of call that out it's like hey you
you can be successful too like that's
kind of like okay yeah
fair enough we have time for one final
question
any yeah with that one like that back
there
so based on what you just said do you
think that being like a good sociologist
is kind of an essential part of market
research and like how have you um like
gained those skills
um i do
and the question is sorry do i think
that being a good sociologist is
important part um
of my job so i'll tell you this i
in general i tend not to hire marketing
people to work for my company i tend to
hire people who come from some sort of
social science um
because i think what's really important
is in marketing sometimes we are taught
to create the voice of the consumer and
i feel like we're living in a time now
where we have to actually interpret what
the consumer is saying to us and create
for consumers what they're looking for
from us and so
i also think it's a very european style
of marketing where they really spend a
lot of time understanding people and
saying okay we now have these consumer
segments and now we're going to create
these products to satisfy that and i've
seen that through you know i've had some
people work for for my agency from
europe and that was very much the way
they came into experience versus i have
the best new car idea and now how are we
going to sell it and so i think that
um
i look for people that bring those kind
of skills to the table because we really
are in a time where technology
is really creating
i keep talking about you know this
democracy where consumers can tell us
instantly and it's never happened before
you know i use this example when i was a
teenager if i wanted to know if gene
cosmetics tested on animals i would call
an 800 number on the back of a package
if someone answered i'd ask a question
and then go with what they told me right
now if you want to know that you can
find out in a minute or less and if you
don't like what you see you can start a
petition on change.org and so
what consumers can do and how quickly
and instantly you can do it
i think has totally changed
what we as marketers do and so i really
look for people who you know cultural
anthropologists people who are really
really
interested in what people want and not
interested in coming in with an
outcome
to cut it off thank you so much tina so
much
you